[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui l'océanie fortement
stratégique cette partie du monde attire
de plus en plus les convoitises des
grands acteurs géopolitiques leurs
luttes d'influencé affecte sérieusement
les relations entre les états insulaires
faisant grimper les tensions dans la
région quelle est donc la situation
politique actuelle en océanie
le 8 février cinq états micronésiens
annoncent leur retrait du forum des îles
du pacifique leur candidat aurait dû
prendre la tête de cette organisation en
vertu du principe de la présidence
tournante pourtant il perd l'élection
face à son adversaire polynésiens un
ripou n'a ainsi un premier ministre des
îles cook les états micronésiens pointe
du doigt l'australie et la nouvelle
zélande les accusant d'avoir provoqué
une crise c'est de la cherche une
coopération plus étroite avec les îles
du pacifique sur fond de confrontation
croissante entre la chine et les états
unis dans la région
la chine et augmente de plus en plus son
implication aussi bien économique que
diplomatique
de son côté washington renforce sa
présence militaire dans la région et
apporte son aide à des pays insulaires
parmi d'autres acteurs majeurs en
océanie les à la france qui possèdent
ces territoires d'outre-mer
développement régional climat et surtout
la sécurité régionale c'est la stratégie
française pour l'ensemble de l'inde au
pacifique le japon lui cherche aussi à
s'ancrer en océanie avec laquelle il est
lié
historiquement
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il faut
savoir sur cette région située en plein
coeur de l'océan pacifique
c'est le blitz cinquième partie du monde
l'océanie représente le plus grand
groupe d'îles sur la planète située
entre l'asie et l'amérique
d'une superficie totale d'environ 8,5
millions de kilomètres carrés saisies
sont divisés en trois régions la
mélanésie la polynésie et la micronésie
à celles ci s'ajoutent l'australie qui
fait partie elle aussi de l'eau saine
du point de vue de leur statut les ils
peuvent être regroupées en deux
catégories d'abord les états
formellement indépendant comme les fidji
le vanuatu où les îles marshall
ils sont quatorze au total ensuite
viennent neuf territoires associés à de
grandes puissances guam la polynésie
française les îles cook et d'autre or
tous ne font pas partie du forum des
îles du pacifique principales
organisations politiques de la région
elle était composée jusqu'à récemment de
18 états et territoires
cinq autres ont le statut d'observateurs
les samoa américaines
le timor oriental guam ou alice et
futuna et les îles mariannes du nord et
l'océanie traverse actuellement une
crise politique sans précédent les cinq
états micronésiens se retire du forum
des îles du pacifique
à l'origine de la démarche le poste du
secrétaire général de l'organisation
attribuer un polynésien les épis
micronésiens accuse l'australie et la
nouvelle zélande d'avoir influencé cette
nomination plusieurs sources indiquent
que le départ de la micronésie pourrait
accélérer l'intégration régionale menée
par wellington et canberra l égard des
îles mélanésienne et polynésiennes il
existe pourtant un facteur qui pourrait
compliquer si fier ce processus est l'
influence grandissante de la chine dans
la région depuis plusieurs années pékin
cherche activement à s'y ancrer aide
financière projets d'infrastructures
tout cela n'est pas du goût des états
unis qui eux aussi ont de forts intérêts
dans la région afin de contrer
l'influencé chinoise washington rançon
la coopération avec les états insulaires
notamment en matière de défense parmi
d'autres acteurs géopolitiques actifs en
océanie figure la france et le japon qui
promeuvent leurs intérêts nationaux
quel est donc l'importance stratégique
de cette région
quels sont les principaux sujets de
discorde entre les sous- région
océanienne
comment la cession récente de la
micronésie affecte t elle la situation
géopolitique en océanie pour répondre à
toutes ces questions nous rejoignons
fredrik angle vielle professeur des
universités à l'université de la
nouvelle calédonie monsieur lang levier
le bonjour bonjour
tout d'abord pourquoi les réactions des
pays micronésiens est elle si forte est
ce que tu t'es le forum des îles
pacifique et est une bonne idée
on peut penser que c'est lié à trois
choses la natif actuelle c'est le fait
que il ya un système de rotation entre
les trois régions traditionnelles de
l'océanie que sont la micronésie la
polynésie et la mélanésie
c'était le tour des liens secrétaire
général originaire de micronésie et
c'était dur est un ancien ambassadeur de
la micronésie pour les états unis qui
était candidat et le forum du pacifique
acp et l'ue à secrétaire général qui
était un polynésien ancien premier
ministre des îles cook
donc il ya eu effectivement un gentleman
émane premièrement qui n'a pas été
respecté la deuxième chose c'est que ça
fait longtemps que la micronésie a
l'impression que dans le forum du
pacifique le pacifique nord dont fait
partie la micronésie et souvent oubliées
pour les grands d'yves de la mélanésie
on pense à la papouasie à la nouvelle
calédonie aux îles salomon et à
l'immensité de la polynésie
donc ici il y avait le fait qu'il y
avait à la fois depuis longtemps un
certain ressentiment de la micronésie
envers leurs voisins polynésiens
mélanésiens et ensuite quand ce
gentleman appelé mandat était rompu mais
c'est une démarche un peu fort non
où ça équivaut à ce qu'ils ont enduré
dans ce forum
la réaction est un peu forte elle est
partie effectivement d'abord d'un des
cinq états qui ont quitté le forum du
pacifique
dès le 8 février et ensuite les quatre
autres territoires de la mic
onesi c'est à dire 5 sur les dix huit
états qui font partie du forum du
pacifique qui ont dit qu'ils allaient se
retirer selon quand même une procédure
progressive entre février et mars 2021
donc d'une part ça permet éventuellement
à des discussions des accords puisque
cette procédure n'a pas abouti pour
l'instant mais toujours en cours et la
deuxième chose c'est que le forum du
pacifique est avant tout un lieu de
discussions entre les petits états
insulaires du pacifique soutenue avec
une sorte un peu des néo colonialisme
par l'australie et secondairement par la
nouvelle zélande
donc la fois une une association
régionale importante mais qui en même
temps était avant tout politique est par
exemple bouger sur les tendances de la
mélanésie de papouasie où la nouvelle
calédonie donc c'était qu'elle met
justement alors en parlant de
l'australie pensez vous que l'australie
et la nouvelle zélande soient les
instigateurs principaux de la décision
de choisir un candidat incorrectes comme
l'indiquent plusieurs sources
alors ce guide passe c'est que
l'australie est secondaire mans la
nouvelle zélande qui fait partie de son
bassin de deux influences considère que
le pacifique insulaire c'est un peu une
marenostrum australienne et il considère
que les micronésiens sont trop près des
américains en particulier puisque trois
de ces cinq états de la micronésie son
encontre al de libre association est des
états unis
c'est à dire qu'ils sont à la fois
indépendant est contractuellement lié
aux états unis donc et par exemple s'il
vote à l'onu il voit que généralement la
même chose que les états unis d'amérique
donc on peut penser qu'il ya eu
effectivement une sorte de confrontation
de grandes puissances classiquement
alliés mais ayant parfois et intérêts
divergents monsieur en bleu yale merci
beaucoup
nous allons poursuivre notre analyse
tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouverons à la fin de cette émission
pour plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore une fracture de tae se creuse au
sein du forum des îles du pacifique
se sentant lésés par le reste de
organisation les 5 pi micronésiens se
disent contraints de prendre une mesure
radicale les présidents micronésiens ont
convenu d'un commun accord que les cinq
pays lancerait le processus formel de
retrait du forum des îles du pacifique
qualifié par la presse de me crédite
cette décision des poules du scandale
qui éclate le 3 février 2021
lors d'une réunion spéciale du forum
celle ci est consacrée à l'élection du
nouveau secrétaire général de
l'organisation
une tradition non écrite veut que ce
poste soit attribué alternativement un
représentant de mélanésie de polynésie
puis de micronésie
cette fois c'était au tour de la
micronésie et de son candidat gérald
zach moss ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères des îles marshall et actuel
ambassadeur aux états unis de prendre la
tête du forum
pourtant le vote qui se fait sous
couvert d'anonymat donnent vainqueur le
candidat de la polynésie un ripou n'a
ancien premier ministre des îles cook
il est élu par 9 voix contre 8 alors
pourquoi ce vote ne s'est-il pas déroulé
comme prévu le président de la
république des palaos un état
micronésiens à son avis sur le sujet
l'australie et la nouvelle-zélande sont
en réalité les deux principaux acteurs
et si ces deux pays n'avaient pas voté
la micronésie aurait gagné membres du
forum des îles du pacifique l'australie
et la nouvelle-zélande ont
historiquement en poids politique
considérable dans cette région divisée
en plusieurs zones dans fluence la
domination australienne s'étend sur la
mélanésie est celle de la nouvelle
zélande sur la pollinisent la france
elle il conserve aussi son influence via
notamment ses territoires d'outre-mer
la polynésie française est la nouvelle
calédonie au nord il ya aussi la
micronésie qui dépend principalement des
états unis
néanmoins le départ de cette dernière du
forum n'est pas finalement une surprise
totale depuis plusieurs années les états
micronésiens se plaignent régulièrement
d'être peu entendu face à la mélanésie
où la polynésie la meilleure
démonstration en est la question de la
composition du forum après l'adhésion de
la nouvelle calédonie est de la
polynésie
en 16 au forum en 2016 la micronésie
défend ardemment l'idée selon laquelle
d'autres ils doivent rejoindre
l'organisation guam les samoa
américaines et les îles mariannes du
nord
tous les trois sont issus de la zone d'
influence américaine et pourrait donc
renforcer le poids de la micronésie
une initiative qui n'est pourtant pas du
goût des autres membres
le divorce était donc inévitable selon
la presse régionale avant de claquer la
porte
le président de l'un des états
micronésiens aurait même proposé
d'obliger l'australie à se retirer du
forum sous prétexte qu'elle ne serait
pas une île mais plutôt un continent
pourtant selon nombre de médias locaux
c'est exactement ce qu'attend d
l'australie et la nouvelle zélande
quarts en éliminant la voie de la
micronésie les deux poids lourds
entendent désormais accélérer
l'intégration des îles du pacifique
il lit qui se poursuit depuis déjà
plusieurs années en 2016 c'est le
programme australien pacifique step up
qui démarre et deux ans plus tard celui
de la nouvelle zélande pacifique
reset aide humanitaire soutien financier
construction d'infrastructures
renforcement des liens diplomatiques il
fonctionne plus ou moins de la même
façon et sont coordonnées par les
gouvernements australien et nouveaux et
landais
l'autre projet de taille censée relancer
l'intégration est la création de la zone
de libre-échange régional consul ya plus
de dix ans elle devient opérationnelle
fin 2020 la majorité écrasante des
membres sont des états de la polynésie
et de la mélanésie la micronésie elle y
est représenté par un seul état kiribati
il est toutefois peu probable que
l'australie et la nouvelle zélande
puisse propulser leur candidat à la tête
du forum sont le soutien d'un autre
acteur de taille la france selon la
revue ce diplomate paris aurait pu faire
pencher la balance en faveur du candidat
polynésiens en lui donnant deux voies
pas étonnant d'ailleurs sachant que le
gouvernement français entretient des
relations de plus en plus étroite avec
l'australie
les deux pays signent en 2019 en accord
historique de coopération stratégique
pour une durée de 50 ans et qui opèrent
conjointement avec la nouvelle zélande
dans le cadre de l'accord france censé
aider les états insulaires du pacifique
en cas de catastrophe naturelle les
responsables politiques français restent
pourtant silencieux au sujet du récent
scandale
tout comme le gouvernement américain
d'ailleurs qui domine largement la
micronésie mais qui entend répandre son
influence dans le reste de la région et
cela principalement pour contrer la
chine de plus en plus présente en
océanie
quel est donc l'intérêt de pékin dans le
pacifique comment les états unis
renforcent style leur position enfin
quels sont les autres puissances
régionales impliquées dans cette partie
du globe
la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
la compétition s'accentue actuellement
autour des îles du pacifique les poids
lourds géopolitique cherchent de plus en
plus activement à 6 ans crée surtout à
renforcer leur présence dans ces eaux
dans l'importance stratégique est énorme
l'océanie attisent depuis des siècles
les convoitises des principaux acteurs
géopolitiques et cela pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord et avant tout c'est un
positionnement fortement avantageux qui
permet de garder un oeil à la fois sur
l'asie et l'amérique ainsi que de réagir
de manière opérationnelle à des menaces
dans les eaux du pacifique
historiquement les deux poids lourds
géopolitique en profite et dispose
depuis des décennies d'un important
contingent militaire dans la région
la france et les états unis pourtant si
pour ces deux-là la présence militaire
en océanie est plutôt une question de
prestige international
l'australie et la nouvelle zélande en
font un sujet de sécurité nationale elle
augmente progressivement leurs budgets
de défense et mènent régulièrement des
exercices militaires
conjointement avec leurs partenaires
étrangers
du point de vue économique l'océanie
représente un important débouché
commercial isolé de la terre les pays de
la région nécessite constamment
différentes catégories de produits et de
matériaux de l'alimentation et des
vêtements jusqu'à des hydrocarbures et
des machines électroniques sophistiqués
circonstances dont profite de nombreux
pays qui exportent ou le nécessaire dans
la région les etats-unis la
nouvelle-zélande l'australie et le japon
ces dernières années pourtant un autre
acteur géopolitique fait son émergence
en océanie la chine en plus d'inonder
les marchés locaux de ses produits elle
investi progressivement dans les
secteurs minier agricole et gaziers de
la région
tout cela pour des raisons économiques
mais aussi géostratégique
l'autre facteur qui ajoute de
l'attractivité à l'océanie sont les
importantes ressources naturelles dont
regorge un certain nombre d'états et
territoires de la région
par exemple la nouvelle calédonie
russell 10% de toutes les réserves au
mondial de nickel
l'australie elle possède d'immenses
réserves minérales dispersés sur son
territoire fer uranium bauxite plomb et
zinc
c'est également là que se trouvent
plusieurs gisements d'or faisant partie
des plus importants au monde situé au
plein coeur du pacifique l'océanie est
aussi connu pour sa biodiversité marine
exceptionnelle truite moules crevettes
et surtout ton la pêche industrielle y
prospèrent les états insulaires en font
un commerce lucratif en vendant des
licences de pêche à des pays étrangers
certains comme le japon taïwan les états
unis et même la france on achète
volontiers région riche en ressources et
dont le potentiel stratégique est
indiscutable le cni et attire de plus en
plus l'attention de la chine pour
s'approcher des petites îles pacifique
pékin recours à sa stratégie préférée et
compte sur sa puissance économique
c'est tout d'abord l'aide économique
directe ou sous forme de prêt entre 2006
et 2010 est la chine a fourni près de
1.5 milliards de dollars d'assistance
aux îles pacifiques et vers 2017 pékin
devient le troisième plus grand donateur
de la région cependant la chine
un autre atout les investissements dans
les infrastructures
la plupart des pays de l'océanie ont
souscrit à l'initiative chinoise des
nouvelle route de la soie
dans ce cadre la chine investit
massivement dans plusieurs projets à
travers la région routes ports bâtiments
publics et d'autres cet engagement
alimente aussi les liens commerciaux et
sinopacific de 2005 à 2007 les
exportations chinoises en océanie sont
multipliées par six et les importations
ont été multipliés par presque neuf pour
la chine ces liens ouvre l'accès aux
ressources naturelles de la région en
plus les avancées économiques permet à
pékin de recueillir des dividendes
diplomatique en hausse et la chine vise
tout d'abord en évincer taiwan en 2018
première victoire la papouasie nouvelle
guinée dégrade le niveau de ses
relations avec taiwan et en 2019 pékin
décroche
deux nouveaux alliés qui étaient proches
de taiwan kiribati et les îles salomon
je crois vraiment qu'il ya beaucoup à
apprendre et à gagner de la république
populaire de chine et le rétablissement
de nos relations diplomatiques n'est que
le début
cette percée chinoise attire
inévitablement l'attention de washington
qui ne compte pas c'est et ses positions
en océanie cela va de soi que nous avons
besoin d'un dispositif de forces plus
robuste est mieux réparti dans la région
indo pacifique face aux capacités de
contre interventions et aux avancées de
la chine
car pour les etats unis c'est région
représente bien plus qu'un groupe d'
îlots paradisiaques d'abord 3 et halo
faut pour teasé par pékin sont en
association libre avec les états unis
la micronésie les îles marshall et le
palau il accorde un droit de passage à
l'armée américaine en échange d'une aide
économique
de plus les états unis sont présents
directement dans la région via trois
territoires l'état de hawaii les samoa
américaines et l'île de bois cette
dernière accueille notamment deux
grandes bases us une navale et une
aérienne avec près de 6000 soldats somme
toute guam et le principal avant poste
militaire américain en asie face à la
chine et la corée du nord
c'est sous donald trump que commence
l'effort américain pour contrer la
percée chinoise en océanie son
administration a misé sur sa puissance
diplomatique et militaire en mai 2019
donald trump invite trois dirigeants de
3 pi pacifique associés aux états unis à
la maison blanche une première
historique pour la micronésie
les îles marshall et le palau en août de
la même année mike pompeo seront en
visite en micronésie et marque le
premier déplacement d'un secrétaire
d'état américain dans la région
je suis là aujourd'hui pour confirmer
que les états unis vous aideront à
protéger votre souveraineté votre
sécurité votre droit de vivre en liberté
et en paix ces mots se matérialise en
mars 2020 avec l'inauguration de
l'initiative de
dissuasion pacifique elle prévoit un
budget de plus de 2 milliards de dollars
pour augmenter la présence militaire en
océanie et cet élan se poursuit sous joe
biden dès 2021 le pentagone cherche à
accroître le financement de l'initiative
de dissuasion de pacifique 27 milliards
de dollar jusqu'en 2027
selon défense news le but est de gonfler
les capacités défensives de guam et de
hawaï approfondir la coopération
militaire avec l'australie est aussi de
créer de nouvelles bases dans la région
au-delà de cet axe de rivalité
sino-américaine il ya aussi d'autres
acteurs qui cherchent à s'affermir dans
l'océanie
c'est avant tout la france comme les
etats-unis la france administre
plusieurs territoires d'outre-mer en
océanie nouvelle calédonie où alice et
futuna polynésie française et clipperton
des zones où se trouvent notamment des
bases françaises avec 2900 soldats
c'est sur ces territoires que porte
avant tout la récente ouverture
pacifique française dans le viseur de
paris surtout la nouvelle calédonie en
elles se préparent à tenir un référendum
d'indépendance avant le vote en mai
emmanuel macron fait le déplacement vers
l'archipel pour rebâtir ses liens avec
la métropole
la visite est marquée par un passage
historique du président dans la grotte
d'ouvéa
trente ans après la prise d'otages par
des indépendantistes lors du scrutin le
non à l'indépendance l'emportent de même
que lors du second référendum en
nouvelle calédonie qui a eu lieu en
octobre 2020 j'accueille cette marque de
confiance dans la république avec un
profond sentiment de reconnaissance
j'entends la voix de celles et ceux
qu'anime la volonté de l'indépendance je
veux leur dire c'est avec vous ce n'est
qu'ensemble que nous construirons la
nouvelle calédonie de demain pourtant
paris regarde aussi au delà de ces
territoires pacifique en 2018
aussi le président formula nouvelle
stratégie française pour l'ensemble de
l'un d'eux pacifique s'engager pour le
développement régional le climat mais
surtout la sécurité régionale et là
liberté de navigation pour cela paris
multiplient des exercices militaires
dans la région par exemple les vastes
manoeuvres pitch black organisé en
juillet 2018 par l'australie ou encore
les exercices avec les états unis et le
japon en février dernier d'ailleurs la
frégate prairial dépêchés pour ces
manoeuvres et restait déployée dans la
région en 2021 paris préparerait aussi
un sommet france océanie
cependant le français portent surtout
sur les relations avec les poids lourds
de la région
c'est surtout l'australie 1-1 importante
partenaire sécuritaire français la
france est le dernier grand pays de
l'union européenne après le bric 6 pts
qui a une telle présence
indo pacifique qui un tel ancrage et qui
donc peut-être ce trait d'union entre
l'australie et l'europe
assumant pleinement notre part pacifique
entre temps la stratégie pacifique du
japon vise au contraire à des nations
insulaires
car ces îles sont d'anciennes colonies
japonaise et les liens sont toujours
forts tokyo accueille tous les trois ans
le sommet des dirigeants des îles
pacifique avec la prochaine réunion
prévue cette année face à l'amptp lanta
sion chinoise la diplomatie japonaise
s'activent auprès des îles et multiplie
les visites tokyo fournit aussi de
l'aide à la région et son engagement
s'accroît encore plus pendant la
pandémie exemple 17 millions de dollars
d'aidé économique à la papouasie
nouvelle guinée ou encore 9 millions
pour la gestion de la pandémie dans dix
pays du pacifique pourtant les efforts
japonais ou français en océanie sont
tout de même éclipsé par la compétition
sinon américaine sous joe biden comment
va évoluer cette rivalité des grandes
puissances dans l'océanie
quels rôles peuvent y jouer paris et
tokyo pour y voir plus clair nous
rejoignons à nouveau fredrik en deux
vielles professeur des universités à
l'université de la nouvelle calédonie
monsieur angle viel est ce que l'océanie
peut devenir bientôt un nouveau champ de
bataille entre les etats-unis et la
chine compte tenu de l'activité a crû de
pékin dans la région alors sein des
banques est la conception que l'on note
du pacifique sud
c'est annie il ya deux conceptions je
dirais divergentes sur le plan extra
théo la géostratégie ceux qui voient le
pacifique avant tout en fonction des
bordures et c'est évident que sur la
bordure ouest on à la russie et la chine
et sur la bordure est les etats unis
d'amérique et donc les grandes
puissances je dirais se pose toujours la
question cet immense océan pour la
communication et la défense il ya une
deuxième façon de voir l'océanis ses
devoirs l'océanie insulaires et à ce
moment là ce sont plutôt les puissances
régionales que sont l'australie la
nouvelle zélande voir la nouvelle
calédonie et haïti avec la france qui
joue un rôle sans oublier hawaï qui
évidemment est un point très fort des
états unis d'amérique en plein centre du
pacifique nord quel quel pays a
aujourd'hui les positions les plus
fortes dans cette région alors vous
posiez la question invectivant de la
place de la chine
il est évident qu'aujourd'hui la chine
sort si on peut dire de son isolement
il faut se rappeler que la chine
historiquement jusqu'au 12ème 13ème
14ème siècle envoyer des gens un peu
partout dans l'océanie et que c'est au
14e siècle que la chine a décidé de se
renfermer sur elle même
aujourd'hui après 400 ou 500 ans
finalement loin du champ pacifique
la chine a décidé de s'y intéresser à
nouveau
pour quelles raisons bien entendu on
pense tout de suite à la pêche et aux
droits de pêche
on pense aussi aux communications aux
ports et aux déplacements de la marine
chinoise
et surtout il ne faut pas oublier
d'avoir des points satellitaire par
exemple la chine a fait beaucoup
d'investissements au vanuatu ex
nouvelles-hébrides en plein centre de
lahm et anizy parce que c'est un lieu
qui est parfait pour les lits de
satellites qui entoure la planète et la
france selon vous at elle les moyens et
la volonté de contester le leadership
dans la région alors le présent la
république française emmanuel macron a
tenu récemment un discours dans lequel
il a rappelé que la france souhaitait
que la calédonie la polynésie française
et wallis et futuna soit un peu les
vitrines de
l'europe pas simplement la france mais
aussi de l'union européenne dans le
pacifique et que je dirais c'est je
dirais c'est ses pions s'est avancée de
l'europe en plein océan soit aussi là
pour répondre aux enjeux liés à la chine
et aux possibilités de développement par
rapport à l'asie et on pense en
particulier au fait que la nouvelle
calédonie est le troisième producteur
mondial de nickel et donc il ya déjà des
accords avec des usines chinoises avec
des fondeurs coréens
donc là il ya une volonté que les
relations économiques se développe entre
la chine et la partie francophone
françaises du pacifique
monsieur angle vielle merci beaucoup
pour les explications fredrik angle
vielle professeur des universités à
l'université de la nouvelle calédonie
était aujourd'hui avec nous pour
apporter son éclairage merci encore
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]